Thanksgiving wasn't always like it is
today the domestic family Neil football
parade leftovers Black Friday like
Christmas it used to be a holiday of
festivals outdoor revelry and drinking
and much like today's Halloween in fact
children would dress up in costumes and
go begging for money or treats if you
were growing up in 19th century New York
City you might see a group of cross
dressers called the fantastical
marketing the city streets ridiculing
authority figures it wasn't until the
mid 1800s that Sarah Josepha Hale the
godmother of Thanksgiving as we know it
started writing her famous editorials in
Godey's magazine recontextualizing the
holiday as a domestic occasion one in
which distance sons and daughters
returned home for a family feast she
urged governors and presidents to adopt
the last Thursday in November as a
national holiday and her letters shake
with notes of urgency and despair as the
country slid into Civil War Thanksgiving
she hoped might hold together under the
banners of brotherhood and gratitude a
fragile union it didn't work of course
but in 1863 President Lincoln did make
Thanksgiving a federal holiday a point
of pride for Union States than for the
rest of the country as it rebuilt after
the war
hail Lincoln and others of that period
effectively rewrote Thanksgiving as
something that happens indoors with
families a joyful reuniting but no
longer a raucous one the tectonic
changes of the industrial and commercial
revolutions were pulling families apart
they felt threatening to weaken the ties
and values that grounded the nation over
the next decades into the 20th century
Thanksgiving lost its tolerance for
begging children and drunken marchers
and picked up new traditions like annual
football games and the Macy's Day Parade
teachers taught the story of
Thanksgiving to their students many of
whom urged
immigrant parents to celebrate the
national ritual a way of stirring
patriotism and as with all forms of
assimilation foreign cultures are both
absorbed into and erased by the dominant
culture the Thanksgiving turkey and its
many side dishes are a great metaphor
for these twin tendencies and many
brought dishes from their own cultures
into the feast to remember their diverse
pasts as long as the turkey rained
overall this is all to say that
traditions like Thanksgiving aren't
natural by any means they're invented
and at the time of their invention they
call to a past that's not really there
an imagined past a constructed
authenticity that serves the purposes of
the present indeed even the awareness of
such traditions is a relatively modern
phenomenon anchoring points for a
culture in constant and progressively
more rapid change there's a lot in the
DNA of Thanksgiving worth holding on to
but there's a lot of which we'd be
better off without a rosy and false
account of our early settlers friendship
with the Native Americans an ideology of
female domesticity an anachronistic
remnant of the separate spheres way of
thinking that said a woman's rightful
place was at home in front of the stove
the assimilation of other cultures races
and classes into a largely white and
largely Protestant system of thinking
for me the core of Thanksgiving is
family the family I was born into the
family I chose the community I live in
and the nation that gives me the freedom
to think through and if I one criticize
its values these days in the wake of
terror around the world when our worst
reactionary tendencies are flared by
those far too willing to stoke fear and
anger it's worth remembering I think
just how many different families we all
belong to we may be celebrating in
separate homes but in reality each
family in America blends into the next
if the history of Thanksgiving shows us
anything it's that holidays like these
are open to revision as Americans
Thanksgiving is ours to reframe just as
the country is that's an important
responsibility for all of us a
responsibility for which I give thanks
hey everybody thanks for watching and
happy Thanksgiving to everybody out
there I hope you're with your families
or with people that you love I'm going
home to my family and I can't wait to
see all them if you want to support the
nerdwriter if you think that the
nerdwriter is something that you're not
seeing anywhere else on YouTube or the
internet you can go right here and
pledge to my patreon page little as a
dollar per video everything helps you
guys have been amazing so thank you for
that this money goes toward improving
the channel and making better and better
and better videos and I hope your guys
are seeing a return on what your your
giving to me because it's very very
generous and I don't take it lightly so
thank you guys again Happy Thanksgiving
and I'll see you next Wednesday